que vous avez entendu si je comprends
bien que nous avons une
une réunion privée en petit comité qui
était très intéressante
et nous avons procédé à un échange
d'opinions sur la façon de continuer à
promouvoir les intérêts de l'énergie
sur le plan international
et quels sont les objectifs
documents rédigés évidemment la
situation est un peu différente
cette année en raison des choses ces
cinq dernières années
nous allons proposer l'année prochaine
un nouveau document aux précédents
donc à certains noms mais porte encore
de potentiel
conflictuel s'accumulent vis-à-vis des
dans les relations avec les partenaires
et à
ses partenaires occidentaux qui ne
veulent pas avec la paille est dans une
atmosphère de dialogue ouvert mais qui
veut et constructif mais qui veulent
simplement d'imposer leurs positions et
se lâcher des commencé déjà dès les
années 90 aux chiens ensuite de les
promesses de non développement d'armes
nucléaires et
menés au score et
nous considérons que c'est quoi ce n'est
pas dans nos intérêts à ces six pros qui
[Musique]
de droit et de respect mutuel et de
recherche des équilibres d intérêt
d'autant plus super spectacle
nous avons beaucoup de gens qui
partagent nos idées se sont dits proches
de nos économies économique gracia tic
rubrique ce chandail de la cellulite
mais quelques incertitudes
d'autres partenaires
en asie en afrique en amérique latine le
certains pays
notamment africaines laser
l'union des pays cibles amérique latine
et des caraïbes absolue et donc le salon
de bing
propose de nouvelles alliances
d'intégration comme je sais ne voulons
que le droit international soit toujours
est toujours la primauté dans le monde
dont la finale
en 1975 il
ny
occidentaux avaient demandé que les
recettes respecte de l'augmentation plus
personne ne veut de sa
justement à je m'étais ce droit pour les
occidentaux proposent de monter
un nouvel ordre fondé sur ce machin
c'est très simple les pays sont présents
sont
représentées toutes les positions
ce qui se passe comme c'est ainsi qu'il
faut chercher chercher justement sur le
fond les pays occidentaux se réunir
de prendre les questions qui sont
l'ordre se fera dans
les traités selon kaboul mais sans
social est ce qu'on se bat sur cette
discussion est restée mac os x
avoir rien de sortir d'une telle force
de travail et ceux ci ont fabriqué des
décisions 30
qu'on distribue d'étalon aux autres à ce
moment là je veux marcher pendant un
certain temps
fors lépi pas de plus sur lesquels le
plaisir les pays occidentaux une
ambulance le mythe ni gommer quelques
jours cela n'aura jamais aucun cas perso
de stabilité parce que je
sais les accords qu'ils ont conclus
entre tous les participants de
fonctionner
c'est là aujourd'hui la
contradiction essentielle face au
barcelone l'international qu'on ne
pouvait pas mieux on s'attend
aujourd'hui
après on voit plus que
ces tentatives de réécrire l'histoire
après la fondation
connu à l'issue de la seconde guerre
mondiale et certains se considèrent
aujourd'hui comme les seuls élogieux
vainqueur de cette guerre et c'est une
illusion qui ne présente aucune
perspective je suis convaincu que de
plus en plus de responsables politiques
à l'étranger dans les pieds de police
que d'autres en prennent conscience on
en parle certains parlent de manière
privée c'est quelque chose de très clair
et ce en travaillant de concert
de façon collective que nous pouvions
évidemment c'est plus difficile de se
mettre d'accord que quand on est entre
réussi
tous les honneurs par abdou fall moment
là on va vraiment établir repas ou un
équilibre du centre
les accords qui sont réalisables et qui
sont qui peuvent être respectées
est ce qu'avec l'allemagne et nos
services vous êtes en train de se
refaire une nouvelle c'est fatigués de
ces restes au menu wii fit manger il ya
une certaine facile mais on ne lâche pas
de flammes mais avec nos collègues yeux
le coup c'est donc ce n'est pas très
correct comme tous les jours pour gagner
les deux dernières années par exemple
quand lors de cette visite est de
discuter des initiatives de se retrouver
au niveau des pays des responsables que
cela fait cher et surtout
de ça ils font des accusations en disant
tout ils veulent avoir ne joue pas et
c'est
donc qu'il y avait eu des
dix enregistrement
de la discussion poutine m'a choqué
certains
discussions l'instant je forme à
l'amendé et l'appel du président
français la chancelière allemande
et le président poutine a mis d'accord
rencontre des ministres des ministres et
responsables informatiques ont dit et je
vais me sentir
comment il faut
juste que je suis décision des
rencontres précédentes dans les formats
dans le monde ils devraient chuter ce
qui me définit
rempli par le régime de vichy
n'envisage meugler rencontre
ministérielle et c'est bien
alors que nous fait la plupart ses
interlocuteurs de ne la pièce ne voulais
pas avoir une discussion de simplement
faire photographier en ce qui concerne
stoch lac l'obligation deux
échanges c'est tout
c'est pas l'action de savoir qui a
rythmé
le fond le pass ne cesse de chaque sens
de sap qui a été mené par le régime de
kiev il avait des marques qu'ils ne
veulent pas honoré leurs engagements ils
veulent touré
ministre ce que donc il s'est en
badigeon de chaux las de ces deux
réunions
dans l'espoir que autour du temps de
françois
je le sais qu'il se soit la droite
routine on pourra lancer tout à fait
inacceptables
j'ai vu ce qui a été publié
cette lettre de monsieur je dis que
c'est plus qu'il est ministre de la
défense peut-être
enfin c'est plus important
des territoires occupés
j'ai écrit à la commission devenait
souffrait ces deux lectures
intéressantes comme eu aucune chute il
ya peut-être qu'un images dieu écrite en
petit et ce qu'il ce tout cela est
consacré au fait que la corde minsk n'a
aucune valeur
on commence à se rencontrer sur la page
soutenable il medias la même solution
présentant ce qui inquiète
les russes ne vont dire qu'ils les
russes sont d'accord avec
encore le choix de nos uniquement
ceux qui étaient tous invalidés plus
risqué que qui est français
c'est tout c'est le statut particulier
l'australienne
amnistie aux jeunes et ce sans condition
pour gagner lors de cette élection
conformément l'obtenir ce qu aux accords
conclus entre kiev et chez tonnet c'est
tout à partir de ça c'est vraiment
rétablie en une drôle
par le gouvernement
craignant
les régions tous sont en fonction hier
vers personne ne peut le nier c'est
écrit noir sur blanc
facile à rome
est-ce qu'il faut passer à de nouveaux
instruments pour stabiliser la situation
les yeux le président oui le président
faisait effectivement une autre
appréciation sur ce qui se passe dans
le secteur de la bière noire
nous voyons aujourd'hui des provocations
évident que c'est toi de ce que tout le
jeu tu sais qu'il me reste des chasseurs
il énuméré graphistes chefs notamment
s'étaient fut parfaitement se montrer au
cinéma le
lascaux ii ce qui saute aux yeux si
c'est pour une bonne claque qu'ils les
jumeaux reproduction et ses joueurs
risquent de pierre de se montrer
victimes de se poser en victime de
l'agression de l'agression vous vous
souvenez ce qui s'était passé les
voitures en occident quand c'est
des trucs je sais
bien que tout supporter
tu cherches halozyme ce chiffre les
tensions a provoqué
pour que la route irish du craag dans
l'espoir qu'ils aient déjà
le principe de
chercher les étrangers et c'est
vers la défense indien qui faisait car
c'est curieux et vocale et du ministre
le club a longtemps les déclarations
seraient installées dans la nature
défendu nous l'ukraine sur une action de
brûlures sont des gens
essaient de
nous distraire l'attention
la
colline donc ici sur l'arène
internationale
nous allons faire tous les deux
[Musique]
et ils parlent de leur grande bretagne
ou du mal internationale
espace ont provoqué deux c'est
difficile tout son potentiel
en tout cas
plus grand celui de soissons à la fois
amusante
évocatrice on voit que nos corps et une
âme les gens sérieux massa comprennent
bien que tôle en ukraine un chaton de
personnes dans ces durs des postes haut
placés ou claude provost delà de ces
gens taux qui aura des conséquences
graves ces jours là je ne peux nous a
foutu une chambre chez vous vient
clairement dire je suis au mieux avant
de vous je me pose cette situation
dangereuse et washington un premier doit
comprendre c'est sûr que je sens une
machine à dire bien je vous remercie